[Music]
everyone just saw that didn't they
yeah
pretty much yeah everyone saw the
kissing booth and as a result jacob
allordy's personal life became major
public interest so much so he almost
quit acting because of it i learned a
lot about myself the actor covers gq's
first ever hype issue and inside the mag
jacob opens up about his overnight
success after starring in the 2018
netflix rom-com
how about a ride
come on shelly you know my mom will kill
me if i leave you out here
jacob recalls after the film dropped he
woke up to 4 million new instagram
followers
quote i had to go through and delete my
high school pictures because that was
the instagram i used for my life i wish
people could understand how drastic that
change was get ready for life you know
and with the sudden rush of attention
and scrutiny jacob says he wanted to
quit acting he understands that might
sound quite sensitive and dramatic but
doubles down and explains i am sensitive
and i'm very dramatic i hate being a
character to the public i felt so far
from myself and as we now know jacob
didn't quit instead he made two more
kissing booth movies kissing booth too i
miss you jerk i miss you more and
kissing booth three
what
[Music]
you want to live with me
no
yes of course i want to live with you i
want to do everything with you and
jacob's relationships first with kissing
booth co-star joey king and later with
model kaia gerber only brought more
attention and more paparazzi jacob
remembers the first time he got snapped
his mindset shifted in a not so good way
it felt like all of a sudden i was a
poster like i was a billboard it felt
like it was for sale that my brain went
through the ringer like i wasn't sure if
i was genuine it really skewers your
view it creates a very paranoid way of
living
but by 2020 jacob told e.t he learned
how to navigate it i think initially it
really bothered me um just even the fact
that somebody would could be someone
that you don't know
knows your name is quite like
disembodying
uh but then eventually i think
i just for me personally i'm just it's
got nothing to do with me you know it's
like imagine
the store around the corner from where
you are now and whatever people are
talking about it's not your business
it's kind of how it feels it's like
unfortunately just has my name involved
in it but
it just it literally has nothing to do
with me it just doesn't affect the
trajectory of my life so just kind of
ignore it you know
but thankfully seems the effects of fame
aren't enough to stop jacob from maybe
giving fans another kissing booth flick
someday if there was a fourth movie it
come back in time is it 10 years 20
years later is it kids in the picture
where where's what's the era for you i
think i'd like to see them all in a
nursing home together
yeah that would be cool that would be
quite interesting and then maybe it's
like
it's like the film is like a series of
monologues of them recounting everything
that happened from 20 to 92. yeah so you
think you think l and noah make it the
long the long haul i'm not sure if they
do or not but that's what i would
i just think it would be interesting to
see that
[Music]
you